Hello, sweet internet.
I'm Gav.
I'm Dan.
That's DJ Dan. We're The Slow Mo Guys.
A while ago, we did a video
where we spun a CD so fast,
it shook itself to pieces.
It sort of warbled and then flung out.
Warbled?
Yeah.
Well, okay. Well, this time,
we've got some records.
We're kicking it old school.
Yeah.
I feel bad breaking these, to be honest.
It's almost like ripping a book.
It's just not to be done, is it?
I know what you mean, but we did,
I did get them from Goodwill,
so I feel like people are done with them,
they've experienced it,
now we're gonna put them to a second use
in a second life, so...
Immortalized forever on the internet.
So this is the loading procedure.
If you didn't see the previous video,
then I'll explain something.
This is actually the motor
from the inside of a...
I think it's a Dyson,
so it can spin at incredibly high speeds.
I think that's probably all right.
Imagine putting a needle on this,
what it would sound like.
It would be...
It's already kind of wonky.
This record isn't perfectly straight.
You know, when you see them
being played on a gramophone,
they kind of go like...
Yeah.
Like that.
I don't know if this is
going to survive long.
So, because we're just using
the motor from a Dyson,
it's an incredibly fast hoover motor.
That's how it works.
It spins really fast.
But if you were to just
turn it on straight away,
it would be spinning at maximum speed,
and that's just kind of not what we want.
We want to get the gradual buildup,
and then eventually the
breaking of the record.
So, for that, we're
going to use this Variac,
which means that you put
the voltage through it,
and you can vary the output,
increasing it gradually,
until we hit that exact
breaking point we need.
I'm excited.
Yeah, me too.
Slightly scared, too.
Yeah, it makes a hell of a noise!
It's really intimidating.
Shooting on the v2640.
We're going to start at
12,500 frames a second.
I think if this works, we'll paint one.
All right.
Paint one with different quadrants
so you can see it spin better.
Sounds good to me.
This damn vice is going everywhere.
This thing so powerful,
it's, like, shaking the vice all over.
I need to, like, tighten it down.
God. That goes!
That goes, whoa!
Look at this!
Oh, it's, like, colored it.
It's turned it into...
Oh, geez.
That's crazy!
Where did it go?
Well, it just got eviscerated, I think-
Oh look, there's a big chunk of it there.
That's a big chunk.
Bugger.
Yeah, I was all the way over there,
and some tiny little, like,
tiny little fragments were, like,
bounced off of this and went...
Little bits of musical dust.
Yeah. Dust.
I think that was, you know what?
I think that took more than the CD.
Really?
I think so.
Look what it's done to the wood here.
It's like embedded
itself in the wood fully.
Almost cracked the wood open.
This is lethal.
I'm actually glad we put these up.
Yeah.
I was getting worried that
we were going to send it
across the fences.
Well, if this piece is like
this, then it's possible.
At this speed,
it's almost like you could
play the music at it.
Yeah. This is the music speed.
This is actually, what is actually-
It's just slowed down to the .
Is it wobbling? Yeah, now it's wobbling.
Oh, you can see on the reflection
that has got a wowowow.
It must just happen at certain speeds
where it's like, ah, now I'm warping.
It's weird because it
stabilizes initially.
Woaw!
Wow!
What the-
That's like a chunk of
it's still on there.
Okay. Let's do that frame by frame.
Okay. So it's split from the middle.
See that crack's started?
Yeah, I see that.
Worked its way through.
Turned into like a tree, either side.
So wait, it looks like
lightning going through it.
It pretty much does.
And that means that one,
like each of those halves
is now like really vulnerable to cracking.
Ah. Look on the left,
they're just going .
They just turned to glass.
Like they just turned to dust.
It's kind of good that
we've got the blocks there,
because it like shatters
it after it's gone.
Yeah.
Because there was some big chunks
coming out of that.
That's, I think we should move the
blocks on the right side.
Just slightly.
Woo. Wee.
Oh, it just hit the edge.
I think just for safety, we
should build up one higher.
You think so?
Yeah. Like this is coming
off at some ridiculous clip.
What?
Because we've got enough light,
I'm just going to change the
shutter angle to 90 degrees.
Each exposure is now
20 microseconds approximately,
which should, well, get rid
of half of the motion blur.
Oh, I also need a shield.
I'll just hide behind that wood thing.
Or the tree.
Too far away.
Too far away?
Yeah. The wires don't reach.
Yup.
Woaw.
I was like, there's not
much more to give on this.
Really?
Yeah. I was nearly full whack.
I was nearly full whack.
There's surely know where it's set at
full speed with that on it.
Like the motor is only
meant to spin a small fan.
But maybe because the record is heavier,
it's slowing it down more.
So it's not being able to
get the same RPM as the CD.
Yeah. This one's cracked
slightly differently.
It's not in such a straight line.
It's gone like sideways.
You can see the marks
it's left on the brick.
Really?
Yeah.
Do you wanna watch this, Liz?
Okay, you ready?
That one was different because
it cracked from the outside.
See the crack at the bottom now?
Yeah.
Three, four, five, six,
seven, eight, nine frames.
It was gone.
That broke really similarly to the CD.
Yeah. That was because it
broke from the outside.
That was exactly how the CD went.
And then it just misted itself.
It's like glitter. Look at the sparkle.
So let's move everything six feet back.
God. So much effort to
move these kinds of props.
It's ridiculous.
So we thought we'd make it easier to
to be able to do maths on this.
So painted quadrants.
Well you painted-
I say I painted quadrants.
It's not really-
Its blue is questionable.
It's got a sort of slightly
bigger piece of the pie.
You just complain about everything.
I can't do anything right.
You didn't say do like
an amazing job of it.
It was just like a basic thing.
Sorry I didn't measure
out to the millimeter.
God!
Should I preface everything now?
Oh, by the way, do an amazing job on it.
Yeah. Otherwise I'll just
do a shoddy job. Obviously.
I like it. I think it's funny.
Okay. It's locked in there.
So let's play a guessing game.
Yeah.
So there's always a piece
that goes straight up
and it doesn't shatter.
What color do you think it will be?
I reckon blue.
Oh, yellow.
Yellow?
For sure.
All right.
I wonder what color that will
look like when it's spinning.
I mean, if it was red, green, and blue
it would appear white,
but because of the yellow-
Appear yellow?
Yeah. Maybe.
Let me just document your shield.
All right. Well, first of all,
I've got to be in comfort.
So I've got a nice recliner behind here.
So that I can do it in comfort.
And second of all,
I'm hidden behind, here with the Variac.
I'll like use my head to
shield myself, turn it on,
and then just like .
Golly. Gosh, me.
So I ended up breaking 115 there,
but it's only got this much more to give.
So it's really at the limits of-
It's hungry.
Yeah. It really is.
Hungry lad.
Yeah. It was another crack
from the outside, that one.
Should I see?
Yeah.
Oh wow. It looks cool
with the colors. Isn't it?
It's like a really convoluted
way of paintings something.
Yeah. Blue went up.
Dammit.
Without even seeing the slow-mo.
You can tell which colors went where.
Because if you look, green
is all at the bottom there.
Follow it around and it's all the red,
then it slowly turns to blue.
Well, that's, that's why the sky is blue.
Gotta be the last of that.
And then there's more blue
and then it goes yellow.
I think it broke more or
less perfectly in quarters.
Blue, yellow, green, red.
We're now looking at this edge
to see how much it warps.
Oh, the whole wood top went .
Oh geez.
Oh, look at that!
Look at the damage it's done here.
Oh, God!
That's insane.
That is insane.
It looks like scarring.
Look, you can see the individual pieces
that have hit it and the way,
the fact they've gone more
wobbly as it goes along,
then come back again.
It's gone, like you can see a graph where
it's gone wobbly and then not so wobbly.
But I bet if it carried
on, it'd be like this.
Like a wave, like that.
It's a way to record
onto the physical media.
Yeah. Look!
It's like an instant graph.
It goes like this, like that,
and then it comes back around again,
and it goes like a wave
all the way around.
I bet that's exactly what
you'll see on the slo-mo.
That is a severe amount of warp.
Wow. I'm surprised to
see it's even managed
to stay in focus, it's
moving around so much.
It's just appalling, isn't it?
It really is.
Ah, this goes from the middle.
Ah, did it?
Yeah.
I was hoping it was split
exactly on the front focus line.
Well, that would be amazing.
I wonder what the, like
how much centimeters-wise
it was actually varying in wibblement.
I don't know.
I guess we just do one more.
Ta-da!
What a beaut.
Well, thank you.
This one is being shot square
so we can stabilize it in
post and spin the shot.
In theory.
I've also got the wood
in the shot, so if we see
any of that scarring, we've
got to see how it did it.
Oh yeah.
Powering up engine. Starting jet.
Oh!
Good Lord.
One came directly at this thing.
Did it?
I heard it audibly like go .
There must've been a rebound.
There's no way it would
have come straight at you.
No, exactly.
It must've like rebounded off the stone.
Ah, from the outside again.
From the blue.
So let's see which bit came at you.
It came off the corner.
That must've been what hit ya.
You think so? It must've.
It was coming at the same sort of angle.
Look how fast that's spinning towards her.
I definitely almost felt it though.
So it must've been the chunky piece.
Did you say my name?
Huh? A chunky piece?
Yeah. That's my nickname.
Look at the 3D nature
of some of this stuff.
It's just absolutely compressed.
Get some side on.
It looks like someone's taken like
mascara and wiped it on a brick wall.
It looks like someone's just
going like yeah, yeah, yeah.
Found some more.
Do you know what's good about that video?
What's that?
We've shattered all the records.
Is that good?
What do you mean?
Like you're doing a record breaking pun?
Well, yeah.
Yeah. You know what, with your puns,
you're like one of these.
Like broken record?
There you go.
That was insane.
We never had this cage around it last time
when it was the CD,
because it was so light.
It just lost all its velocity.
Like the drag from the
air slowed it all down.
This stuff. This could have gone miles.
Well, the very fact that this still exists
after hitting the cage
just tells you like, this
is super thick as well.
Right in the middle,
it's the records are thicker
than they are the outside.
So the outside bits hit
this and turned to dust
and these would go flying.
But luckily most of the energy
is taken up by hitting that.
Now these parts, the bigger A,
because they were in the center
and they were released
at a slower velocity,
and also the label sort
of holds it together.
Yeah. That was crazy.
I'm glad it's over. Cause
that was kind of scary.
What I might do.
I might take a picture of these
and post it on Twitter and I'll say,
you'll never guess how
we painted these bricks.
No one will get that.
I don't think anyone'll get it.
I don't think record has ever been used
in that way before.
No?
No.
Well that was a record
breaking record breaking.
Yeah, I think it was.
Yeah. Well I think it was
a record breaking squared.
God. Well that was cool.
Hopefully you enjoyed that video.
Feel free to subscribe to
our very channel right here.
We've got second one as
well. Behind the scenes.
I play pranks on Dan a lot. Don't I?
Yeah, you do.
Yeah, I do.
And all the social medias and stuff.
Thank you very much for watching.
Do you know in the future?
Yeah.
When like, you know how
we have like archeologists
that would go to places
like Rome and Greece
and that together all
the pottery and be like,
this was used to store grain.
Do you think there's a
future that will find these
and be like, hmm, well,
and they'll glue one
of these all together.
It appears to have been
shattered apart by itself.
Yeah. Yeah.
This is where you grow grain.
That's what they sound like.
Or the guy from Time Team,
it was like, Oh right.
This, this,
The guy that wasn't totally rot.
Yeah. The one with the long hair.
He was cooly faking a West country accent.
Yeah. As soon as he got on
camera, it was just like,
Oh you talk like this now. I
just talk like this normally.
And then a cut.
I thank you.
Thank you, John. My trailer.
Yeah.